the Joe Rogan experience and I'm not
afraid I don't I don't know [ __ ] I don't
have yeah I don't I just got some
experiences I'm not an expert at nothing
everybody that I sit across from his way
smarter than me yeah and I'm fine with
that
let's have a conversation I want to
learn that's good that's not that's what
that's probably why you're successful
it's the way to thing world people be
like oh I can't believe you would say
dude you would ask Elizabeth Warren
about her Native American answer did you
see that bro Rachael's by now too but
did you see the interview with him and
Elizabeth Warren yes we're out on the
Native American [ __ ] but you know here's
the weird thing about her it's like I
don't necessarily think she told the
truth in that interview I don't know how
she did it away with it when she said
that the Boston Globe did an
investigation they said that she didn't
she didn't in any way profit off of that
or have an advantage she got here she
got hired for not from Harvard and she
wrote Native American on a resume like
they hired her based on her ethnicity
yeah yeah she's a liar yeah that's a lie
yeah which is fine I don't have no
problem with my politicians lying they
do it all the time but I want you to
acknowledge your line hold yourself
accountable like none of this [ __ ] is
disqualified it's not the 80s anymore
it's not the 90s where [ __ ] like that
ruins you just be honest like look I'm
American I've cheated before I've taken
shortcuts I [ __ ] used to put the
cheat code in Mike Tyson all the time
just to get Mike Tyson to skip everybody
else that's what we're based on yeah so
if she did that at some point her life
was it a horrible thing to do absolutely
make it a table for her make our
terrible present forever no I buy what
she was saying though that she was told
that she was Native American cuz many
people were and then they find out when
they get a DNA test this knife did not
happen to you didn't help you yeah well
hasn't been disproven yet but yeah what
are you Native American yeah I was like
growing up around the time I was going
to college my god that works my dad
found out that he he like filed the
paperwork to to his college ten years
after the fact and got a bunch of money
back and so my dad's like well we're
Native American that's what I we've been
told our whole time so we're trying to
prove it all right it's birth
certificate and whatnot and it's really
hard to because they didn't keep a lot
of information back then right so I put
it on a application got into Ohio State
that way taught them and it was real
weird when I was in like the minority
home they just liked on the orientation
day there was like they gave me a letter
to say show but this like Elizabeth you
got from a hard-working Cherokee kid did
it in good faith I had no idea and it
was the first time just like when I sent
in my application and it was like what's
your race I was like I just found out
I'm a Native American I guess so I'm
gonna put that and no one checked no one
asked
that's hilarious that people know just
ya know I didn't know I was doing
anything wrong
that what the wild thing about that is
like that that conversation is like
people ask me why I said that I'm like
I'm just too dumb to know that that
wasn't a question I wasn't supposed to
ask you were supposed to ask that a
conversation the idea that you're not is
ridiculous that's a huge thing we need
to find out how she reacts to the fact
that she told a lie the rest of her
family is the did that [ __ ] up the whole
lineage right this whole whole family's
thought tearing [ __ ] down off the wall
like oh my God we're not Native American
how many dreamcatchers were in the
garbage that we printed holy [ __ ] just
feathers sticking out a hefty bag what
she learns that then the whole family
after realized that we're not Native
American I had to [ __ ] up some family
reunion had to [ __ ] up some tradition
too oh my lord there's a lot of people
that were shaking their head after that
one
[Applause]